[Music]
when I look back on podcasts that I've
done in you know like 2015 or as the
height of like it's just I'm in such a
different chapter now yeah that it just
doesn't feel I don't resonate with it at
all and I think that I mean it's where I
was at the time but I think that if I
look back on it now a lot of it was very
performative I was only just that was
one aspect of myself and I was going to
like hone in on that and it just doesn't
feel like me I mean yeah it was all
about performance and tactics and what
do you eat and how do you train and what
are your life habits and all of that but
from afar I've kind of watched you you
know on this arc this like evolutionary
path that you've been on and you know we
met I think the first time we met was at
the mind body green conference like I
was like four or five years ago yeah
like that yeah
and I just remember like being super
intimidated by you
I was like scared of you like this mega
champion I think there was a hike one
morning and I was like she I'm scared of
that girl man I just but I think looking
back on it now I was reflecting on that
a little bit this morning and I was like
what was it about you yes there's
certain like insecurities that I have
that made me intimidated about your
accomplishments and and what your you're
able to do but I think also like
subliminally or maybe unconsciously I
felt like you also you you like walled
yourself off like you were emitting some
kind of frequency like don't get too
close
yeah and it's interesting because I've
been told that before people people call
me like an ice queen or something um and
I don't I never sleep rejected that I
think that it's very much I think that
that for me comes from place of
insecurity myself and not very much so I
remember seeing you and I knew who you
were and being very much intimidated as
well but not knowing that that that kind
of air of
standoffish 'no static that i may have
liked portrayed a lot of the time with
my own my own insecurities well I think
it's also indicative of you know this
disease that we're going to talk about
you know somebody who's you know been in
recovery for a long time myself I mean
our stories are very different but
there's a lot of similarities I'm going
struggle and all of that and the you
know ultra-endurance but and you know
I'm somebody who's been steeped in
recovery for you know two decades and
have worked with a lot of people over
the years and and I think you know what
it is is when you're harboring that
secret like you don't want your your
intimacy is your enemy you know so the
idea of being open is terrifying to
anybody because what happens if they
find out right what happens if they find
out and for a long time when I when I
thought about you know talking about my
eating disorder it always in the back of
my mind it's like you can't unring that
Bell when you do finally talk about it
and I've had multiple people tell me
that and it's not so much I think that a
lot of is that disorder thrives in shame
the disorder or the disorder thrives in
kind of you know holding it close and
not not being open about it but at the
same time you also worry about how is
everybody else going to view you now now
that they know this and are they going
to treat you differently and for me to
when I've had people say oh you know
you're you're a great role model for my
child to look up to for my girl to look
up to and I thought if I come out about
like am I like am I now you know I mean
when I've been hiding all of this and so
it is very much something that has been
you know it has been kind of like this
difficult this you know this difficult
dance to kind of figure out like yeah
once you let it out of the bag you can't
you can't unring that Bell but the fact
that it's eating away your soul you know
it's like it's you're a ticking time
bomb right so when somebody says to you
oh you're such an inspiration and a role
model
you're like that pit in your stomach
right realizing like you don't really
know you know that for that that fraud
complex right and you you know you don't
you don't know the entire story and so
it's it's for me as this this feeling
people ask me like why why did you talk
about it now and I go it's a lot it's to
kind of a lie in my head in my heart and
who I am yeah you can't be a fully
integrated person right unless you own
that and knowing that you know the
disease thrives in the darkness and
feeds off shame all of that you know
it's ironic because you can
intellectually understand that and yet
it's terrifying to step outside of that
right and I also wanted to make sure
that I was I was actively in recovery
doing things right you know that I and
for so long I I kind of told myself that
I was but then I actually really wasn't
and so did you believe the lie I I knew
that I was not in a good place that for
how long and probably I would say for at
least the past six or seven years I
would say for the entire probably the
entire time that I was in sport I think
very early on in sport I could tell
myself that I was doing well and I could
think that you know like oh no no I'm
just managing it you know like it's
there it's kind of in the back of my
mind but like I'm doing well I'm
competing while I'm winning races I'm
winning World Championships um so how
bad could it be how bad can it be right
like I mean I knew where I had to come
from I knew where I was when I was 16
years old I knew where I was when I
graduated college and you know I was on
death's door for a lot of that time and
I was like I'm not there so at this
point so clearly I it's not that bad
yeah you don't fit the mold or the
stereotype or what somebody who has an
eating disorder looks like and what I
connect with deeply about that is you
know look
we're both type-a competitive people
right we've both had success in our
lives and that success at least early on
in earlier phases of our you know
respective careers was driven in large
part by self well right like I'm gonna
do this I am self reliant I'm taking
responsibility for my path I can't rely
on anyone else and I'm gonna buckle down
I might not be the fastest or the
smartest but I'm gonna outwork that
person and you quickly realize when you
get results doing that that you can
leapfrog over people but if you're also
harboring an addiction you can use that
facility that you have to rationalize
your behavior because as long as you're
waking up at 4 o'clock in the morning to
go running or you're meeting your
deadlines at work and you're graduating
summa [ __ ] laude and all of these things
you can then say well I don't really
have a problem and it perpetuates
the condition that then just continues
to like foment and grow right because
you say well I'm fully functional you
know and that's what I said I was fully
functional throughout all like the vast
majority of the disease you know and so
you say okay is this really a problem
when I am so high achieving when I am
doing all of this but you know when you
when I kind of took a step back and
really looked at my life and this past
you know year or so I said yeah I'm
fully functional but it feels so hollow
you know it feels so hollow um and I
thought that there could be more out
there was that hollowness the bottom or
what was it the the you know multiple
fractures like what brought you to that
place and that you know that sense of
self-awareness where you were ready to
kind of own it in a different way I
think that yes it was it was the string
of stress injuries it was clearly the
string of bone injuries that kind of
gave me a wake-up call that there's
something there's something not working
here but even more so than that it was
the fact that I would like come home to
my apartment in at night after work
after training
and then just look around and be like
all I have is my disorder and it was
much more that I had walled myself off
from relationships from being engaged
you know I couldn't I would go to all
these races but like I wouldn't want to
go out to dinner with everybody else the
night before because I couldn't it was
petrifying you mean you know and I and I
had to do my safe thing and I had to be
in my safe space and that's just a
really really hollow way to live mmm and
exhausting very exhausting lonely very
lonely and you spend so much time and
I'm sure you can relate to this just
trying to protect all that to try to do
your thing and it's exhausting I was so
tired of spending so much time obsessing
about food and I just I was ready to be
done with that right and then every
journalist wants to talk to you about it
no and that's why if you ever listen to
any interviews with me when I talk about
food I always say oh nobody nobody
should nobody take a cue for me on food
and I have been and I will say this I've
I will say that I have been 100%
truthful and all the interviews about
about that um and you know and I was
afraid like what are people going to
think of being now that I've like talked
about these things in the past and you
know talk about me eating pop-tarts and
some pop-tarts I do you don't know
that's well the funny thing about the
the pop-tart thing I mean that's like
your signature really great but what's
interesting about that like looking back
now in retrospect is is the extent to
which maybe you're not maybe I'm
projecting but it appears as if that
that could act as like this foil or this
mask like hey I'm so carefree about my
diet I eat pop-tarts like it's almost
like a defense mechanism right yeah yeah
I think it is like a defense mechanism I
think a part of me now looking back is a
bit over compensation is that I don't
want people to think that I have an
issue so
if your pop-tarts all the time clearly
clearly I don't have an issue I'm at bay
right yeah you know and I think that
also you know eating disorders take all
different forms and so it's not just the
super healthy like orthorexia person
that only eats fruits and vegetables you
know like we all everybody within the
realm of eating disorders it it
manifests itself differently yeah
and we're in an interesting time where
you know everyone's talking about
intermittent fasting and all these you
know the diet wars are afoot and right
we're very passionate about this and now
we're seeing these think pieces coming
out that are kind of shining the light
on how some of these protocols are
really just eating disorders masked
right you know if if you it's all about
your relationship to them I mean I'm
certainly there's advantages to
intermittent fasting and good things
about it but if you have an unhealthy
relationship with that practice it can
be another way of shielding like a
deeper problem right and I think that in
many it for a lot of people that doesn't
rise to eating disorders but it could
arise to disordered eating so how do
what is the the technical difference
between those I well yeah I I will say
that I will speak you know all of this
so this is an in of one for me and so
I'm not you know I'm I don't have
degrees on this so I but so I just want
to get that caveat but I think it really
is when it when it rises to like how how
problematic does it become in your
everyday life you know and so I think an
very thing is probably like with alcohol
is that does it how all-consuming is it
so I don't think that there is like a
hard line I'm sure if you looked at the
dsm-5 criteria between you know what
actually isn't eating disorder versus
what's kind of like disordered eating
practices I'm sure that there's there's
something there but you look around
sometimes and you think god everybody
has disordered eating if you look at
this and I think that that also prevents
people and prevented me I think from
taking help yeah because it was almost
like what's the point everybody seems to
have a messed up relationship with food
nowadays is there anything that is there
anything better
can there be quote-unquote normality but
that's a function of measuring yourself
against other people as opposed to
measuring yourself against yourself and
whatever you feel is missing like that
hole that you were talking about yeah
it's like you know everyone gets a DUI
you know it's like no big deal
you have to get a couple before you know
you can rationalize it and that's what I
was doing for at least for the past few
years was kind of rationalizing my way
out of the fact that I knew I was still
hanging on to my disorder mm-hmm is that
I was was looking around and saying well
everybody's screwed up so why am I so
different and that was actually
reinforced by people when I had a few
people where I would tell them about my
issues and there'd be like yeah you have
an issue with food so does everybody
welcome to humanity right yeah well I
think you know it's it's a it's a
spectrum thing and you know in your case
and I I know I experienced this like the
universe starts knocking on your door
and giving you these little signals like
hey you know this this might not be the
right path for you little cracks in the
art you know the firmament start to
happen and if you don't pay attention
and you still just blaze that path of
like self will forward those dramas
become a little bit bigger and a little
bit bigger and a little bit bigger it's
like it's testing your pain threshold
and you and I like you more than me but
you have a huge pain threshold like you
can suffer your whole thing is that the
queen of suffering so it's gonna have to
get really bad before you're gonna you
know have a reckoning yeah and I think
it has to get really bad but I think it
has to if I look at if I look at my
trajectory and I look look I have
20-year history with this and that I
could have probably white-knuckled the
rest of my life through it without
seeking more help and I think that there
was a part of me thinking that I'm 35
years old like I
be able to handle this on my own you
know I that eating disorders are a young
person's disease that it's something
that I I was recognized I have a lot of
the sheds that I should have you know
gotten over this when I was in college
or the multiple times that I was in
treatment beforehand but it's just that
kind of in the back your mind you're
thinking like there could be something
more like there could be a life more
fulfilling and like more free if I go
through this and the cutting and
baffling aspect of it is this delusion
that you can solve it yourself that you
can apply yourself well to this problem
because it's worked in every other area
of your life like why isn't why can't I
you know make it work here that's the
more you rely on and your I mean like
you told Shane parish like you were
talking about self-reliance and it was
in the context of not being an entitled
person yeah and I understand that but
but I couldn't help but think your your
your your advocating this path of like
you can only count on yourself and at
the end of the day yeah people will come
in and help you but like it's got to be
you and I think that mentality is what
keeps people who struggle with this or
other forms of addiction stuck in their
condition or their disease because
they're unwilling to raise their hand
and ask for help and then accept that
help right and I think that where the
disconnect always happened to me because
I could look at I luckily I knew what I
needed to do like and in terms of you
know rehabilitating my body things like
that like you know what you need to do
you could give me a meal plan you could
tell me probably what I needed to eat or
like I knew what I need to do but
forcing myself to do it on my own I just
I wasn't gonna how couldn't do it and
what happens when you realize you can't
do it on your own you then at least I
started kicking myself and getting this
cycle of self-flagellation saying Emilia
you know what you need to do why can't
you do it and for somebody who yes I
have been super self reliant in so many
areas of my life and to not be able to
apply it to this is very devastate
yeah it's called a shame spiral right
self-knowledge will avail you nothing as
they say and and you know what's what's
relevant to that is I reached out to you
maybe two years ago till I come on the
podcast and and you kind of kept me at
bay for a little bit and then maybe a
year ago you're like I want to come on I
have something I want to talk about like
you know I have this thing with eating
but I'm not ready to talk about it yet
so you had that was a while ago
yeah I've had this self-awareness the
self understanding but you weren't ready
to you know either own it yourself
completely or or do anything about it
until recently
yeah I that's that's very true is that I
I knew you know and and I had spoken to
you that like this is this is a part of
me but I don't feel like I'm in a place
right now where I'm actually doing
anything to kind of to to make myself
better I didn't feel like I was in a
place of recovery and so I needed to I
needed to kind of come to that point
where I realized I can't do this on my
own anymore and I I need to go into
treatment I need to seek a higher level
of care take myself out of my life and
to do that and so that really was kind
of the moment for me in realizing like
yes I at one point I want to talk about
this but I it can't you know it's not
yeah yeah and I was like great when
you're ready yeah you know do it but I
didn't bug you about it like you have to
come to that you know on your own terms
like you you have to arrive at that
place where you have the willingness to
address it and then you know later on
like talk about it but it has to be for
you right I would imagine you've been
foisted into treatment protocols in the
past where you're just trying to get
people off your back as opposed to
really wanting it for your own life
absolutely and I mean I think that's
when I was much younger that's the case
when you're 16 years old and you're
thrown in the hospital like that wasn't
my doing I was kicking and screaming the
entire way or in college I went through
the mo
get people to just so they wouldn't pull
me out of school this time it was no one
was telling me like you should seek
treatment and most people didn't even
know a few close friends knew people
from my past you know clearly knew that
I'd struggled in the past but didn't
know that I was still bothering me so
this time is really I remember calling
up my parents I was like I'm going to
day treatment you know I'm taking a
leave of absence and it was very it was
a very different place for me to do it
all on my own without anybody else kind
of like encouraging me they must have
been happy about that yeah I think so
I mean I think that clearly like they've
they've seen me struggle for so long and
I I actually realize now you know being
in my mid-30s and I'm not a parent but I
can I can't imagine how hard it is to
watch your child go through that and to
be like they you know but she needs to
do it on her own you know yeah so the
day that you decided you were gonna go
to treatment was there something that
triggered that or was it just a slow
awareness that one day you woke up and
you're like today's the day it was a
slow awareness it been kind of
percolating in the back of my mind
probably for the past year or so um and
but I kept telling my something like and
I don't really need it and I remember it
was actually in January
I called opal food and body which is the
place in Seattle to do kind of just an
initial intake eval and then I remember
actually they they they were like okay
this is great you can come in and then I
I I was getting ready prepared to run
Berkeley marathons and I was like no
things are going well like I want to run
I was like we'll deal with this after
Berkeley you know so I was I kept
finding like I kind of pushed them off
and then I finally you know and then I
ended up with another stress fracture
with took me which took me out of
Berkeley and that was two weeks before
mmm and that's I called him up and I was
like yeah let's do that on now it's a
time
you know well before I get into what
that experience was like I kind of want
to track it back to the beginning so
yeah as you said this is something
you've been living with since you were a
very young girl right
it began with OCD right when you were
like six or seven yeah I was I was
diagnosed with OCD probably I was six or
seven um it was in your classic like
light switch flipping type of
cleanliness thing and actually anybody
who knows me now would laugh if they
heard I was OCD because like I'm a very
messy person yeah my you don't have a
Tracy Flick like desk no oh no no no no
like it's just chaos I'm very very
cluttered so I didn't really fit that
classic mold but I remember you know
even when I was like four or five years
old if I couldn't get to sleep by a
certain time I would throw a tantrum or
if I you know if I had these different
like fears and phobias that would come
and go and so those kind of started
pretty early on and then I think that
when I when the food issue started I
think my parents just kind of thought
and I kind of thought well it's just
another manifestation of the OCD and it
will go away in a few months kind of
like the other ones did yeah it's a
phase that that was just another
manifestation because all the other ones
kind of came and went so this one will
kind of come and go so I think we didn't
really think too much I didn't really
think too much of it yeah until you're
like sixteen right when it wins the when
was the first that was the first big
crisis yeah yeah I mean I don't I try
and think about when first time when I
had kind of like a disordered thought
around food and it was a pretty it was
my sophomore year of high school and it
was a pretty short timeframe from when I
first started having like thoughts about
food to you know when I talk like when I
got really sick but I remember being a
sophomore and going to a sleepover at my
friend Kelly's house and we were all
sitting around everyone was like eating
popcorn and I remember that night all I
could do was fixate on that like feeling
guilty about eating that greasy popcorn
and then the next morning like still
thinking about it and thinking about how
I shouldn't have eaten that and and then
I remember like going my mom and being
like I can't stop thinking about that
popcorn and I don't know what's wrong
with me and so and this had been kind of
I mean this food stuff had kind of just
been an over a span of a few months yeah
where I think that I just got
progressively more fearful of it not I
didn't really know why it wasn't a
conscious I think now we think so much
of eating disorders as like a oh well
it's a body image thing there was no
body image involved for me at the time
control it was control it was absolutely
I think I was you know going through
random teenage turmoil and it was a way
that I could feel kind of superior to
people is that I could control what I
put in my body and it was almost this
weird little game for me it was like I
could go out and do you know three
soccer games on X amount of food and
everybody else had to eat more than me
and so it became this kind of fixation
like that yeah you would think that that
impulse to create control in your life
would come from a truant like a chaos
related trauma in the household like
your parents split up whether something
happens where your life feels out of
control but this is the one thing that
you can control but the more I kind of
learn about this world it's not it's not
as simple as that like you your parents
love you and it seems like you grew up
in a you know pretty functional healthy
household so when you look back on that
time like you do you have any insights
about what lead led to that impulse of
needing to exert that kind of control
you know I
the sad part is is that I don't and it's
I guess it's not sad but I remember
being in being and you know recovery the
first time when I was 16 and looking
around thinking almost feeling bad that
I didn't have anything to blame like
I didn't have a trauma my parents were
super supportive we had very normal
relationships with food growing up you
know there was never any diet talked
there's never anybody on a diet trying
to lose weight there was nothing that I
could point to and I think in a way that
almost made it worse for tonight I
wanted I wanted a reason I wanted
something to be like this is why I'm so
messed up but instead it was just like
there I've got it in my head that there
must be something then wrong with me
yeah that I could have this wonderful
life these wonderful parents this
functional family yet there are these
demons in my head and I didn't know why
right it makes you feel broken and also
guilty like you're letting down these
people who did right by you
right exactly I mean my parents the same
thing like there was no alcoholism in my
house growing up my parents are still in
there you know my needs were met and all
of that so it's confusing when you can't
I did like you're almost like I wish
that I could say was this and when you
can't it's it's uh it's like it doesn't
give you an anchor right you know or
agenesis point for this kind of thing
and you have nothing external to blame
mm-hmm and I think you know in some ways
it's so much easier when you can point
to something external and be like that's
it instead you have to turn it all
internal on yourself right and that's
been a pattern through my entire life is
that I will always find the internal
blame first I will never that I don't
blame anybody else you know but it's
always it's always me yeah I would
imagine there is some you know something
that happened that you're unconscious of
on some level like I had I had gab or
mate' on the podcast and you flipped
this equation on me and started
psychoanalyzing me and you know asking
me about my parents and great and it's
like you know his thing is all of these
things result from some form of
childhood trauma by well-intentioned
people that you know we may not remember
or just some emotional need wasn't being
met maybe like you're a hyper
competitive person
on some level did you feel like you had
to be successful was there something
unsaid in the household like where you
know being driven and and
wordly mobile is just an expectation
like I don't know I'm you know I don't
know but I think it's worth it's worth
asking and exploring that but ultimately
whatever is there doesn't really provide
you a roadmap for getting better and
living your life right like if you just
focus on the solution like you can go
down that rabbit hole but ultimately I
don't know what dividend it pays no and
I agree that I and I'm sure that I've
looked at all different avenues and and
things like that but I don't think
finding the reason behind your disorder
or your you know your your choice of
coping mechanisms is actually gonna do
any good yeah it's not it's not
functional no right all right so one of
the things that you've kind of always
said is like well I wasn't really an
athlete in high school but right that's
not the full picture like you were until
you developed these disordered behaviors
and then that kind of sidelined you from
softball and basketball and golf and all
these others were that you were that you
were excelling at yeah I mean I was I
was a very good athlete growing up and I
remember like being in like the local
newspapers like the fear the fearsome
pitcher you know that nobody wanted to
face in softball um but yeah I mean I
lost a lot of weight in a short period
of time and I got very very weak and so
and I think that that was that was part
part of the start of the demise of
sports um and then that you know that
clearly led to treatment and led to
hospitalization and so yeah I was a good
athlete I just became too sick to be
able to compete anymore so you have this
you have this experience where you're
hospitalized between Thanksgiving and
Christmas when you're 16 right so that's
your your first experience with an
institution I dunno and so and this was
back and I mean this was before there
were any types of like residential
treatment facilities or like you see
these nice houses that are like Spa
liked have a treat roadies know this was
a children's ward
yeah children's ward at the hospital and
I was on bed rest for a month um so I
couldn't get out of the hospital bed
and I mean you try and tell a sophomore
in high school that they they can't like
get out of bed and wasn't allowed to see
my friends that was completely cut off I
remember my parents actually snuck in
two of my friends to come and see me but
they just tried I think because they
thought of friends would be triggering I
don't know it was a different treatment
models that's time your parents must
have been terrified oh absolutely
I mean they and they didn't tell me
until after I was discharged from the
hospital but the first night they took
me in there cuz I remember so I went to
a doctor they when I told my parents you
know about my food issues and they the
doctor like did a check-up did all my
vitals and they're like she needs to go
to the hospital right now
and that night in the hospital my heart
actually stopped and my parents didn't
tell me about that until after I was
discharged because I didn't know um but
I mean they were they they almost lost
their daughter yeah and I think that
still kind of pains me to this day yeah
I mean if your if your heart had stopped
at home right you have been a totally
different thing
so you were really lucky yeah yeah it's
it's it's it's scary and it's for real
right and and I think what's you know
what's interesting about your story is
that you're like okay well now its life
back to normal like when you get back
out right like okay that that happened
but yeah I need some therapy but it's
all gonna be fine now right I mean was
that the kind of approach or yeah I
think that so back in the day they would
kind of medically stabilized you at the
hospital and then you just went straight
kind of an outpatient therapy model and
at the time I think that was fine for me
I was just eager to get back to high
school in my mind I was kind of thinking
like okay I went down a road that I
didn't want to go down I learned my
lesson I don't want to be in a hospital
for another month or so so we'll do this
thing and we'll get over it and and just
move on and
it seemed to work I think for the most
part for a few years
yeah well you didn't get back into
sports though you know I so I did a
little bit once ayat was kind of more
stabilized I was able to rejoin my teams
but it wasn't the same wasn't it yeah um
you I kind of lost a year of
developmental time where everybody else
is getting faster and getting better and
getting stronger and so I came back to
the team but I just kind of like rode
the bench right too far behind had lost
too much strength yeah and and so and
that's that's it that's a bitter pill to
swallow for sure do you think that you
transferred some of those impulses to
control your environment on to your
academics I think I had always had those
control I mean the academics that part I
was clearly always like the teacher's
pet control kid from a very very young
age my parents always like you can get
B's and C's it's fine and I was like no
straight A's for me solely so uh-huh but
yeah that was there I actually I as I
kind of tamp down the sports I also went
more heavily into like singing and
musical theater and things like that
right so yeah I just kind of manifested
itself at uprise so but you you graduate
with great grades you got a you go to
college you're you know you're an RA and
you're doing acapella and you're getting
you know your summa [ __ ] laude and the
whole thing like what was the college
experience with this college I did my
freshman year I I did pretty well in
terms of like that I thought at that
point I was recovered I would I would
tell I remember actually telling my
sorority sisters like I recovered from
an eating disorder huh Edie recovered in
the past yeah in the past recovered done
and in the sophomore year I relapsed
really hard really quickly once again
and do you know what triggered that at
the time I think it was like some
tumultuous relationships but it was
nothing very I mean it was all kind of
if I look back on it now
it was all kind of your typical young
adults turmoil right now but it probably
was if you weren't treating it
consistently over the years like it was
just waiting in the shadows right for an
excuse to come back out again exactly
and so I won you know once again I kind
of wish I had something to pinpoint on
it but I don't really in your fault
I know it's it is my fault yeah but yeah
so in in so I relapse really hard my
sophomore year of college and then spent
like the next three years just trying to
get by and I had multiple interventions
from friends from my acapella group
trying to get me out of school and so it
was visibly apparent it was very I was
very very sick so walk me through what
it's like to be stuck in that cycle
because I think there's so many
misconceptions and myths about the
experience of being held captive by an
eating disorder I mean people just think
we'll just get over it like start eating
food eat right oh my god if it was only
that simple oh thank you very much um
that had not occurred to me yeah but one
of the biggest misconceptions and I
think people have reached out to me and
said like I don't know how you were
competing not eating and I go okay well
people with eating disorders eat I mean
that's that's that's you know it's just
always it's a very very controlled
manner and when it depends I mean I'm my
experience has solely been with anorexia
so I can't speak for the other for
bulimia
for binge eating disorder for the other
manifestations but it is just it's all
consuming food is all consuming and the
thoughts of you know how to eat it how
much how not to eat it how to avoid
detection and it is very much something
that as you do get physically emaciated
your mental state also starts to
deteriorate
and it's so part of me I look back and I
go god how was i I mean how did I
graduate summa [ __ ] laude in my state you
know so the but the mental degradation
part of it I mean what is that because
there's also like a like a weird
euphoria when also and that and that
goes hand in hand with like the body
dysmorphia you look like a mirror and
you see you know something very
different than what is objective truth
yeah well I had a lot of shame actually
actually my my I was very ashamed of
what I looked like I knew I was very
sickly and I would try and hide it so I
would I was living and I was in college
and st. Louis and being the winners and
I would like put on like two or three
pairs of tights under my jeans to try
and hide it from people because I was so
ashamed but I and I didn't like how I
looked and I didn't like what I was
doing but I just I didn't know how to
change it and I think that's one of the
things that I that so much of this is
also habit so when you start in graining
these kind of habits and when you start
avoiding something for instance then the
more and more that you avoid it the more
fearful it be the more like power of
power it has so the more you avoid food
and restricting or feel full you become
a bit and it becomes this cycle and you
just can't get out of it I mean you can
but you can but I think that that
powerlessness is what people have a hard
time wrapping their heads around yeah
like how why why can't you just sit
there and write eat them yell and your
answer to that would be I mean I can you
if you sit down in front of me and you
put a plate of food in front of me like
I absolutely can't but like the the what
are the consequences of rank eating that
meal like what what you know walk me
through like what the emotional
experience would be for you if you were
like actually force-fed something that
you didn't want to eat right in that
state I mean it's the it's anxiety that
just goes through the roof so I mean of
not eating the food is the way to cope
with the
society is the way to tamp down the
excitement but if you actually you know
went through the process if I sat down
to eat that entire meal like heart
palpitations the entire time just like
thinking ruminating and then afterwards
you spend all your time ruminating about
that food about what you ate and what's
also interesting is that I love food
people also think that you know people
with eating disorders like don't like
the taste of food or don't know fault I
mean that may be true it's true for some
folks but like you literally at some
point in treatment I remember being like
it was almost like they gave me
permission to eat and I was so happy at
the time because they didn't have an
option so it was almost like I'm gonna
have to eat this relief it was almost
like a relief to give that Wow
do you know who that you know this
person
Eugenia Cooney who ain't she's this
young girl who's a youtuber who
developed a really large audience and
and her her eating disorder just became
writ large like she just dwindled down
and to like a stick figure and she was
putting up all these videos and lots of
teen girls are following her and people
are like you're gonna die like right I
mean it's shocking when you see this
young girl and this and then she kind of
disappeared for a while and last week
this big youtuber called Shane Dawson
he's like one of the things creators on
the platform made a little mini
documentary or I went and visited her to
like see how she was doing and it's
fascinating he goes to her house and he
sits down with her and apparently she
had just come out of some kind of
treatment and he's trying to engage her
in what that was like and how she's
doing and he's you know trying to say
the right things and he's deeply
concerned about her but it was clear to
me that this is somebody who really
hasn't fully owned what's going on like
she's young and and she couldn't even
say that she had an eating disorder and
she's wearing a big sweater and it was
clear that she was still you know either
very early in her recovery or still not
even you know not really in recovery at
all
and if you watch it with a with an
objective eye it's like a I mean second
hour-long video on YouTube I'll put a
link in the show notes you can see the
disease like written all over her face
and how baffling it is because she's
just not really connecting the dots yeah
and I think that in in it's very I mean
I look back at times wonder like I
wasn't you know connecting the dots and
I think that when you're very very sick
sometimes it's it's hard to and you
can't see objectively and you can't
trust your own eyes you can't trust
yourself and I stopped trusting my body
I stopped trusting everything and that's
a very paralyzing place to be you know
and that you you just don't feel like
you have a way out at all and yet you
can you perpetuated this for quite some
time like through law schools what like
you had some dark experiences in law
school yeah law school was so I
graduated from college and part of the
in college I kind of realized okay I I
something needs to be done and so I went
to I graduated from college got in my
car with my mom and drove cross-country
to a residential treatment facility down
in Carlsbad and then I was there for a
little bit and actually that was the
first time where I where I think I
finally embraced like fully surrendered
like I outed myself on everything that I
had been doing to kind of lie and steal
and cheat my way through you know pseudo
eating disorder recovery so I actually
kind of got myself in like a good solid
state before I went to law school but
probably coming straight out of
residential treatment into law school is
not a great idea because as you know law
school is how long was that treatment
experience I was there I think about
five I was supposed to be there about
eight weeks but I think I only known up
being five because insurance ran out
right
and you know it's like these treatments
abilities are like $1,200 a day yeah
yeah it's all about like the aftercare
like yeah what's your program I'm gonna
be when you get out of this right you
know and if you don't have that setup
and you're not making that your number
one priority again you're just you're
gonna revert back yeah and so I set up a
team in Seattle where I was in law
school but it was still very much I mean
the chaos of being a 1l and then the
whole like your 1l grades count for
everything and I mean I almost dropped
out of law school like three or four
times probably the first and only time
my life that I've ever identified as
being depressed you know and so it was
it was a very tough it was a very very
tough transition I'm highly would not
recommend that I was there no exercise
going on during these years yeah so the
treatment mount a lot of the time and
probably for for good reason was that or
this was the thinking at the time is
that you need to eliminate all move men
and I was also at a very stage at a
physical state where it would be unsafe
for me and so I didn't I would say so
between hi I graduated my between like
my freshman year of college through
probably my second year of law school I
didn't do any type of exercise none Wow
and but I was I I was I was a mover I've
always been a mover my entire life you
know like I'd like to move and I like to
be active so I wanted to figure out how
to go back to that
but for some people part of their
disorder is his movement is actually
rise and I was I was fearful that it
could it be a slippery slope for me yeah
yeah the the the real problem is is the
underlying sense of uneasiness that
drives you to feel like you have to
control your environment yeah that can
be manifest in your relationship with
food but it can be also manifest
relationship with exercise or your
studies your academics like your job
like all of these different things are
outlets for that you know sort of
ill-conceived
compulsion right you have like the the
food thing is just how it manifests for
you right it can be alcohol can be drugs
can be gambling shopping whatever and
when you kind of address the
relationship with food it doesn't
necessarily like you maybe kind of
white-knuckling it but if you still have
that it's gonna find another way to eke
out right and it's interesting how you
see so many people in recovery in the
ultra world you know there's a reason
for that
oh no it's like the percentage has to be
crazy high it's it's super high and I
think what the the problem is that when
it comes to for somebody who's in
recovery for drugs and alcohol for
instance or for sex addiction they would
say well exercise is a healthy outlet
for you for somebody who's in recovery
for an eating disorder all of a sudden
those two you have to question yeah is
exercise a healthy outlet for you and
that's actually a lot of the work that I
did when I was at opal was to try and
untangle because I had a lot of
questions in my mind too and I of
whether whether the running you know and
whether the athletics was part of the
disorder right and to try and decouple
those yeah yeah that's that's so hard
because you love the sports right and
this is making your life better in so
many ways so to objectively kind of
deconstruct the extent to which it's
contributing to your disorder is not
only difficult but it has to be like if
you come to the conclusion that yes
there is a disordered aspect to this
then you have to be prepared to
dismantle this identity yeah constructed
about who you are absolutely and and
that in that whole like feeling of grief
and loss that goes with that though I do
have to say I think being having so many
injuries I've kind of have gone through
that grief and loss and a separate yeah
I actually and I I've said this I said
this to my treatment team and that
actually one of the best things in terms
of separating my justement the eating
disorder from sport was being sidelined
with injury because I all of a sudden
been had to kind of it was like a force
separ you've had to reckon with it right
I had to reckon with figuring out like
Who am I beyond this and then also like
is this part of it or is it you know is
this a good healthy outlet for me or is
it something that's driven you know by
disorder yeah yeah and I would imagine
that that your answer to that is
constantly evolving right yeah right
yeah because I don't know I just through
my own lens in my own experience when
people say to me like oh you just you
transferred one addiction for another
I'm like yeah you know I can't I just
sit to a certain extent that is true
like I think people who dismiss that out
of hand are not being intellectually or
emotionally honest so I'm always
monitoring that like do I what is my
relationship to this is it healthy is it
unhealthy and it's always a little bit
of both I think but in the balance of
things it's improving my life more than
its denigrating it yeah and I think that
what I've kind of realized and clearly I
still question this all the time but you
have to look at your intentions behind
the movement and intentions behind what
you're doing and I've realized that
there are for me there are certain forms
of exercise that could be more disorder
that aren't as like healthy and then for
my mental state and then that's also
part of the reason why I kind of moved
from like the obstacle racing over like
into the more endurance side of things
is is realizing that the competitive
obstacle racing like circuit for me
could be very unhealthy if I got caught
up solely in the competition solely in
the podium solely in in you know things
like that
whereas then if I looked at things like
doing the Berkeley marathons that where
your chance of failure is 99.999 you and
you yeah that to me was coming from a
very different place then you know the
this circuit the Spartan racing circuit
yeah that's about winning right and
other people and competition and the
ultra world is really like these soul
explorations you know in certain
respects I mean I'm you know you want to
win your competitor like you know it's
ultimately not about anyone else other
than your relationship with yourself
yeah and there's something about those
training for those races and
participating in them that forces you to
confront yourself in a really kind of
profound way that probably doesn't
happen in a more compressed kind of
competitive event yeah and it's actually
one of the reasons when I first started
getting into sport I mean I was 27 28
that I shied away from races that were
actually like timed and ranked and
judged and had placements you know I
started out doing tough matters solely
because there was no competitive aspect
yeah because I knew that that could be a
like a dangerous path for me uh-huh and
then look what happened I know well look
what happened yeah and then and and then
you know and the things that then came
along with it's amazing because you
became a prisoner of your own success
like yeah came so wildly successful in a
manner in which you know I would imagine
you didn't you couldn't have ever
expected but then with that comes
shouldering the expectations of suddenly
all these other people and sponsors and
the media who are like you're the queen
of pain and like you're the you're the
hardest person and you know like you're
so the expectation is like you're gonna
win all these races you're gonna beat
all the men you're gonna kick everyone's
ass and you're gonna suffer more and and
so when you line up for every race like
just okay like I have to I have to like
you know dance for everybody else once
again like it's an unsustainable model
and I think going back to that first
experience of meeting you and and having
this
sense of who you are at that time like
I've watched you evolve from that person
like when I read when I first started
really getting interested in what you
were doing it's like oh yeah she's
kicking ass in all these races but like
I was like alright you know she's badass
but then when you pivoted to realizing
that you had to find a way to bring joy
into it for yourself and like release
the pressure yeah that pressure valve
that's when I was like and you started
writing about it and I was like oh now
now I'm really interested in what you
have to say and and that's where I think
you know everything that you've done and
undergone that you're experiencing right
now is a result of like what happened
with that right mm-hmm so it was almost
like that pressure valve became too much
you were compelled to like figure out it
how to have a different relationship
with yourself in sport that then kind of
catapulted to you on this trajectory of
personal growth that you know sort of
culminating now and everything that
you're you're doing and talking about
yeah I think I really it is kind of it
was a you know a piecemeal process I
think that that kind of set me up in in
taking a step back and saying okay like
I need to reformulate my relationship
with sport was kind of the first step to
then ending up reformulating my
relationship with myself and it was just
that the sport aspect was easier to
address then you know the the
fundamental you know that the eating
disorder part of it so I started there
but it is very I mean there it's so I
wish that I could segment them and and
say that they're not it not related but
they're completely resource overlaid
yeah yeah Wow
alright so somehow you get through law
school and then you end up in you end up
in Chicago at Skadden yes did you you
had you worked at Skadden not as a
lawyer I was a I was a legal assistant
and in New York Scott Norfolk hey right
out of college before law school oh no I
think and you still lost I know that's
what everyone says and that's what I
asked this is how disconnected from
myself I was like
had I was the world's worst paralegal I
was that place was so huge yeah I could
just hide in my office and like avoid
the phone and like pretty much get away
with not doing anything and I became a
Mike my skill set was like avoiding work
I actually knew some associates like
that too
I mean I worked there for two years and
and I had a whole crew of like young you
know right out of college friends and we
you know we would run around the city
and so I had a great time and it's it's
not totally fair like I you know I did
my job or whatever but it wasn't exactly
a fulfilling you know environment I'm
like man I can't believe I went I just
went to law school because I thought
that's what you're supposed to do and I
really didn't really occur to me to even
explore doing anything else but I was
there
1989 291 like I'm like in the middle of
like crazy M&A but oh yeah that place
was like on fire yeah oh yeah I can't
write imagine like being a lawyer there
yeah yeah I I know I know
um you know I was in the Chicago office
which I think that helped look we were
not as crazy as I think just the New
York culture which for law firms is
really really tough Chicago you get a
little bit more of the Midwestern vibe
and whatnot um I actually loved being
out of firm I actually really really
enjoyed my time at Skadden it was I was
in so I graduated in 2009 so basically
right after everything I mean Bear
Stearns had collapse Lehman's it
collapse and so I went into
restructuring in bankruptcy so we were
very busy but it was kind of like
business is good
yeah the schadenfreude of all of that
but I actually really enjoyed it I just
I think for me I didn't I didn't see i
saw partners and i was like that's not
what i want to do you know but you how
long were you it's gotten six years oh
wow yeah so that was you know I stayed
another year or two and you were you
know that's the partner deal
well oh god I know Scott is a single
tier partnership so it's more like 11 or
12 but I think I just also I really
like in legal work I really like being
in the weeds and I really like kind of
the drafting and the process and things
like that and then I realized like as
you get older you look up partners all
their time is spent like the schmoozing
in the business not all the time but
schmoozing and business development and
that just I was not I wanted to do like
the grit see I would have preferred the
other way around I was that person
everybody else do all that work like you
know you can go lock yourself in that
conference room and go through like 300
boxes of documents yeah I'll go out to
dinner with the client networking events
I would find any excuse to avoid them so
it's like that's that's not for me well
and this is the period of time in which
you reconnect with being an athlete and
have all this success and and I remember
just reading about you and kind of
watching this whole thing unfold and
thinking like you're you're winning
every race that you're in and you're
working and like I I know and appreciate
like the pressure cooker environment
yeah in which you're practicing law I
just kept thinking like she's one of the
few people that could actually make a
living as a professional athlete and
define you know a new way of being a
professional athlete and like leave the
law and like do this full-time the law
is always gonna be there you can you can
go back to these law firms and I was
confused as to why you you'd like having
both yeah I I well I could technically
have made a living as as a you know
professional obstacle racer but for me
it would have changed the character of
what I did I mean if I thought I put
enough pressure on myself to go out and
win World Championships when I knew that
I could go back to like you know my law
job that if I didn't win the world
chairmanship it didn't mean that I
wasn't gonna be able to eat the next day
so in my mind if I made it my profession
it would change the character of what I
was doing it which is already a very
tenuous relationship I mean if I if the
competition was getting to me and I'm
just like your ultimate weekend warrior
imagine if that was my livelihood
so it was a place for me of being like
nope nope gonna try and still keep that
joy in there which you know had its ups
and downs you still had to meet your
maker with it right you kept your job I
know so I don't I mean I don't know I
had it had I decided to to quit and
become you know a professional obstacle
race but this is also there at the very
very early stages that I got in this
sport like before anybody would even
call it a sport in today some people
still won't call it a sport so I wasn't
blown up you know it's it's a huge thing
and you you I mean you definitely could
have stepped out and like made a career
outside of the law yeah I made that
choice yeah but I never I never actually
seriously considered it like beyond just
kind of brief moments here are there of
feeling well yeah but I'm already almost
30 years old who becomes a professional
athlete there's 30 years old never
moments though where you're getting
ready
you know it's Thursday or Friday
afternoon and you've got World
Championships that weekend or some big
race where the partner calls and says
hey we're all meeting you know tomorrow
Saturday morning at the firm in the
conference room I like call it off okay
that works
yeah I there were I did skip a lot of
races last-minute
I always booked flights refundable
because they just you know never
happened around world championship those
I actually did make sure that I took
vacation time even though we know that
doesn't necessarily always mean that
you're protected um but yeah I mean
there were I remember I would be you
know drafting or sending out emails at
10 p.m. the night before a race you know
that's just yeah part of it or I would
finish the race and then go check my
email and be like oh and they're like
why aren't you responding this is
everything yeah I think I saw it block
around that time I know I know you just
crawled out of a mud pile after carrying
a log through a lake right I don't feel
like I'm sorry we didn't have any so and
that was the issue a lobby's races
there's no cell phone service
we're so then I'm sitting there thinking
like oh my god am I getting email from
somebody that Korea time war anxiety
absolutely just checking it yeah and
what was the food relationship like when
you were competing and at your best and
during this phase um I think that I was
kind of rationalizing everything that I
was doing in terms of Adina's like a
well and performing well so it doesn't
really you know Matt I was like I'm
doing well so what I'm eating must be
okay
yeah and doing well is an understatement
I mean you're suddenly you're on the
cover of all these magazines and you're
getting all this attention like the
accolades are just raining down upon you
so I would imagine that's disorienting
when it comes to really taking honest
stock and inventory of your behavior
yeah and I think that I to be totally
honest my eating habits were probably
have probably been very similar these
through the entire time it's just that
it took that many years for it to catch
up to you yeah probably I mean that's
that or instead of it's like you can
delude yourself in your mind for so long
that you are doing fine but the body
doesn't forget as easily and you know
after a while it starts to catch up and
I think I also probably didn't realize
at this point you know that I was like
not getting periods and that my bones
were deteriorating things like that and
so it just it became a after a while
your body will break yeah well you were
diagnosed with osteoporosis when you
were in high school yeah so when I was
16 I think they did they did a DEXA and
you know all the z-scores at the time I
they don't call it osteoporosis at the
age they called League osteopenia um but
it had so I was diagnosed with I'm gonna
16 I had another one done when I was in
my early 20s and I'd gotten better and
so I think that they were like okay it
can reverse and and you know increase
from there but I didn't know you know I
have a history of this and I broke a lot
of bones when I was even a little kid
because I have just had a small bone
frame right oh so you're coming off this
you know streak of just winning all
these races and then suddenly injuries
start to appear that means that how it
kind of begins well first there's the
there's the serve reconciling with the
pressure yeah yeah well where was the
time line so what happened was that I
basically at the end of 2015 I had just
won like my third world's toughest
mutter and I remember I was ready to
walk away like I was ready to walk away
from the sport just because I just it
was I just felt overwhelmed by the
pressure and I almost thought like maybe
we should just go out on top you know
like one these these titles and just
sail off into the sunset and I think I
was kind of just tired of the circuit
and then I actually discovered
ultrarunning
all right that kind of thought about
that to give it a go at this point I'd
also this was when I I'll of Skadden
moved across country to go to Apple
what was that decision about that
decision was I think I in my mind it was
partially to have a better lifestyle
more suited to competing in terms of
that I worked actually just as much now
as I probably did at the firm but it was
just thought it's on a more regular type
of like hourly that in-house lifestyle a
little bit more conducive also I knew I
wasn't gonna be a partner was I was
pretty middle-of-the-road associate and
was not on my radar and it's not
freezing cold and then um I also wanted
to get back West you get back out west
because I'm born and raised in Portland
and so that was part of all that went
into and I remember coming out to
California and seeing like the beautiful
trails the trail had like ten minutes
from the Apple campus and being like yup
there I'm there I am and so I started
getting targeting ultras and I ran Sean
O'Brien down here
100 K in 2016 got a golden ticket to go
to western states and I was like whoa we
started training bunch more and knew
nothing about how you should like
increase coach right no no coach yeah
smart yeah wrong with you I know no
coach well because in with obstacle
racing the vast majority my training was
actually CrossFit and then I ran maybe
like 15 to 20 miles a week but it was
nothing and then we thinnest I look
actually my training log cuz I did kind
of keep one and I went from running 15
to 20 miles a week - then prepping for
western states and running like 80 90
miles a week and like two months yeah so
that's when I broke my femur yeah so
that was the first injury anyone would
have broken you know and so and I think
that the the femoral stress fracture I
was able to write off as kind of like a
the training just was not dialed in and
so with one bone injury you can probably
do that but when they start to pile up
longer so you have this femoral fracture
which is no small thing but you don't I
mean it's impossible to get you to sit
down for five minutes like you're just
doing all kinds of crazy training around
it
yeah I eight mile crutches hikes and
whatever funny thing is people people
talk about that Spartan Race that I did
on crutches and that had nothing that
was that was mainly for I still I still
I'm glad that I did that because that
was for like the adaptive athletes and
seeing a different experience that
wasn't about trying to race but yeah I
mean I as soon as I was cleared to do
anything which was literally the day
after I got the diagnosis I was in the
pool with a pool buoy and between my
legs trying to so I'm trying to do
anything and I could to like still be an
athlete and I think also at this time
all of a sudden I had been managing my
eating disorder but then I was then
looking at four months of no running and
I didn't know how to feed myself right
because part of part of the
managing your eating disorder met an
exercise routine like you know your
calculus about what to eat is very much
informed by how much you're training
right and when you're benched suddenly
that equation gets thrown out the window
and you got to figure out a different
way of dealing with it yeah but I also I
think that I could write I go well so
many my other athlete friends have that
exact same feeling too when they all of
a sudden are injured and they go I don't
know how to eat or like I should
probably stop eating as much and so for
me I sat there and thought okay well
that's just normal that's not an eating
disorder they don't have eating
disorders so does that mean I have an
eating disorder or like you know so I
was part of that mmm rationalization
it's hilarious that you're confused
about asking yourself that question
though well I thought I said well I mean
I did have an eating disorder but is
this part of it now and I think that
that's really hard to untangle yeah Elan
yeah so it becomes indelibly clear
though when when you suffer the second
fracture right like when you finally are
able to kind of train again and then you
fracture your sacrum yeah um I I mean
the the femur stress fracture is hard
for me because I was trying to do
everything I could to stay in shape and
to get back for World Championships and
I didn't realize it at the time but I
dropped a lot of weight when I was
injured which and I it was not
intentional and and I think a lot of it
I also a body type that and I've
realized this too is that when I run I
actually my body gets larger I put on
muscle and things like that and vs. and
I build it really easily but yeah and so
I got so I dropped a lot of weight and
then it ended up with a sacral stress
fracture which was clearly like a psycho
stress fractures can be training our
errors but they're generally like
there's something going on your body
that's not right
and that was when I kind of started to
think like
this is getting out of control again
because also what happens is when you
when you know when you start to when you
start to like lose weight you can also
then unintentionally get back into like
the mental states that there there's all
this research about how about you know
setpoints and people in their set points
and that when you go into like a starved
state you're like the obsessions become
that much worse you are you aware of the
key study mm-hmm I don't think so okay
so back in the 40s is the Minnesota
starvation experiment where they
basically took you know a group of
healthy adult men and they starved them
and that you can't do this nowadays
because I mean like clearly there's a
lot of reasons there's a constitutional
amendment right but these men
volunteered to be housed and basically
sorry I know can't remember how much
food they gave them but it was so
minimal and they started exhibiting
all of the traits that you see people
with eating disorders oh right I can
actually provoke it impede you kind of
provoked it if you starve people down
and they I think they saw very much
because the point of the study was
actually to figure out what was going on
in like the Nazi concentration camps but
it's still to this day one of the best
studies and the only really study that
we have about the effects of starvation
on people and what that does to their
mental state so what is that
specifically like what they become more
body dysmorphic or more like fearful of
food yeah so the more that they you
actually like withhold food from people
then they they will become fearful or
they'll start hoarding it I mean all
those salt rationing it so you see with
a lot of people - eating disorders that
they may take a very long time to eat a
meal or something so these men would be
like well I only get this amount of
calories a day so I will stretch it out
they would start obsessing over
cookbooks recipes you know nowadays you
probably see this on like Instagram
people looking at food porn
and they would just by not feeding your
body then all of those things became so
much worse right and it's funny actually
the first few weeks that I was or the
first week that I was there at Opel and
I remember finally like I was full like
really full and I go you know it's funny
I have stopped obsessing over food
because I'm not hungry when you're
[ __ ] hungry like you obsess over
everything
it's amazing that when you actually feed
yourself thing the thoughts don't go
away
yeah it's not as simple as that but yeah
so it's an interesting it's interesting
what actually just the physical
starvation will do to your mind mm-hmm
and it doesn't have to be you know it
when people think starvation they think
zero food but it would be interesting to
to apply a similar study to what goes on
neurologically during intermittent
fasting or the seven-day fad because
it's so the rage right now and you know
are we having the real conversation that
we need to have around this like you'll
hear a lot of anecdotal evidence that
I'm more mentally focused or you know I
can pay attention better but what is
happening hormonal and neurologically
that's contributing to that and how much
of that is healthy versus you know
leading you towards that you know
disordered relationship with food well
and I think that the more that you get
you see people do that then with like
their cheat days and then they just go
like hog well you know they'll restrict
restrict restrict restrict their food
intake and then just like one day a week
go hog wild and then go back to so it's
just this I don't understand I call and
you know and and I think that i think
that it's tough because I don't think
diets and things like that cause eating
disorders but if you have a
predisposition to that kind of stuff
that's clearly not helping and you know
we've we're taught so much that we
should not listen to our hunger cues or
that that we should you know we do
anything to like suppress our appetites
like when did have an appetite become a
bad thing yeah you know there's so much
about the culture right now that's tough
and I think with with the you know the
diet Wars that we're seeing
or the way that people talk about diet
on social media and on YouTube etc it's
it's it's easy for people with
disordered eating proclivities to hide
behind whatever protocol they're
advocating whether it's vegan or paleo
or keto or you know fad whatever it is
you can kind of become you see people
who you can kind of tell like this
person has a [ __ ] up relationship with
food and they're they're just you know
like singing from the rafters about how
great a certain diet is but beneath that
is an unhealthy obsession like this
obsessive kind of thing that's driving
the whole machine yeah absolutely and
there's a lot of there's a fair amount
versus that is that show that if you you
know if you forbid certain things in
your life you're seriously going to then
clearly crave it more and more and so
the people who say you have to make it
evil right exactly and and or you can
only eat between periods of time and we
are creating this machine and it's
really just this entire the thing is in
now and now it's not even people say
it's not a diet it's a lifestyle change
and I'm like no no that's still diet
culture just under a different like yeah
that's a good point
and you look at a so many of these diets
are consumers selling products they're
selling things to us it's amazing when a
new kind of diet comes on you know
online and how quickly the marketplace
comes in to like fill it with all of
these products and it becomes like
co-opted and packaged in a certain way
and then market it and sold to us
absolutely I mean if you look at now
everything on the shelves is keto this
you know that you know and then and it's
no different than growing up in the 90s
it was low-fat fat-free everything and I
think that's really hard for people to
kind of like sort through a lot of the
times especially when we have to eat
yeah like I can just not drink
hey I do drugs and it's you know
obviously this is elementary but like
you have to eat every day yeah so you're
you're forced to confront
you're conditioned in the most you know
tactile way three times a day at least
yeah and I and it's what's interesting
and I've told you that you know I have a
history of going to a oh hey
because back you know 10 15 years ago a
lot of people treated eating disorders
like an addiction because that was a you
know model that we had you know that a
model worked very well I remember going
to a lot of a oh a median stirring
during college or during law school and
thinking like man this a thing doesn't
seem to be working well for anyone and I
think because there's a different a
works great because you guys like or you
know you can be with other people and
not and be around alcohol things like
that doesn't work for food because you
have to eat to live you know and so it's
not as simple as just avoiding it and a
lot of the mindset has gone away from
treating food like an addiction that
it's not and it can't be treated like an
addiction and so I don't know the the
science is still morphing on it and the
the treatment models but yeah I mean I
don't I don't suffer from that condition
and you know I I don't have a scientific
opinion on it but I think that the if
there is a disease aspect to it it's not
the food it's the impulse to control
like I'm talking about before and and
twelve stuff whether it's Oh a or a a is
all about like getting you to you know
turn your gaze inward and do an
inventory of how you're behaving to get
clarity on on who you are and like make
amends and and you know be able to get
you know clear on what your character
defects are and then have this community
that holds you accountable yeah and and
that's it was actually kind of sad for
me when I remember looking back into
treatment a you know two or three years
ago because I loved the 12-step culture
and I found it very very helpful for me
and I'm being like wait no one's really
doing that for eating disorders anymore
friends that are in Oh a yeah yeah yes
you should do yeah we have some
bang for a long time they get to be
helpful I've never been to a know a
meeting but you know a lot of them are
people who are cross addicted like
they're like what I know from a they
just go to both mm-hmm you know it's all
the same thing like the more I kind of
you know live on earth I start to see
all of these things as one thing and
something that every single human being
you know can identify themselves on a
spectrum yeah we're all guilty of
behaviors or thought patterns activities
substances whatever it is that we
compulsively do on some level maybe it's
minor for a lot of people but that we
can't seem to stop ourselves from doing
even though we're suffering adverse
consequences like hey why do you why are
you constantly dating [ __ ] you know
whatever why do you have to go to the
mall three times a week or why you know
why are you watching soap operas it at
11:00 a.m. like all of us you know have
our little vices and you know in certain
respects the person who you know can't
pull the needle out of their arm is the
easy case because the problem is so easy
to diagnose and treat whereas somebody
food it's harder you know the
relationship thing it's even hard it's
like it's really hard to like
deconstruct what the actual problem is
but I think they're all manifestations
of something very similar that we all
share just in being human absolutely and
I think one of the things that I've
realized with the number of people that
have reached out to me and you know
after I you know open up about this a
lot of people would start an email
saying like I don't have an eating
disorder but I have XYZ or I've
struggled with x y&z I'm like it doesn't
you know food was my coping mechanism we
all have a co-payment right um you know
if food was food was that for me and so
but it's underneath it's all the same
language you know and then a part of me
and then I get in my mind and I'm like
why like then why are we I mean a nerd
I'm like what is it about the human
condition then that like we're all
currently in this day and age it seems
that everybody seems to be struggling
with these something underlying this
yeah I don't know maybe life's is too
easy and comfortable
you talk about beautiful people talk
about that's why you know why that's
what marathons is why this whole world
exists yeah people have to figure out
how to inflict some pain on themselves
and I'm part and parcel of that you know
alive I know you know frame well you've
had you know your journey through this
from super-competitive to finding joy in
it and now this you know like latest
chapter how well first actually first I
want to get it I want to I want to get
into like what actually happened it
ovals so you go you go to the you go to
the treatment center like what is the
experience like what is the protocol of
trying to understand how to you know
resolve this issue and get you on a
better path yeah I mean every treatment
facility is a little bit different so I
was in a day patient so it was like 8:00
to 8:00 to 6:00 p.m. and then you do all
your meals and your snacks there and it
really is ten hours a day of talking
about your feelings which I actually
think is incredible actually here is how
I think the world this is how I think
the world is gonna be a better place
everybody needs to go talk about their
feelings for 10 hours a day everybody
should go to treatment I know what
that's like
anybody who identified from treatment
you get to like opt out of your life and
just go to this place and all you do is
work on yourself yeah anytime it is but
I think that I finally what I needed to
do was I had to create space for myself
to finally actually confront everything
and you know the first few days I
remember kicking and screaming I
remember calling up my parents call them
friends being like no this place not for
me I might use those yeah well it wasn't
I say with my sister so it was it was 8
to 6 p.m. and then I had oh I slept at I
was wondering cuz you were like posting
on social media routes yeah yeah I
didn't some people got mad at me that I
didn't clarify that I wasn't in a
residential or inpatient facility by
right but I think I didn't want to I
didn't want to spend my time being like
this is a partial hospitalization
program and it's you know it's 50 hours
a week but yeah so I
I didn't warrant the inpatient level of
treatment but I think that a lot of what
they used at opal and treatment Allen is
radically open dialectical behavioral
therapy which is for people with
diseases but over control which really
spoke to me because everything in my
life has been about that over control
peace and then just trying to take a
step back and when you when you strip
away all of your coping mechanisms so
you strip away the ability to control
food I stripped away you know the
exercise sport piece which you know I'd
kind of I'd kind of done the work on
exercise sport piece through injury and
through rediscovery and joy and then all
of a sudden you're sitting there and
you're looking at yourself and you're
like okay now this is me like I've
gotten rid of my coping mechanisms and
you kind of like you feel very very raw
and you know I'm sure you can relate I'm
super vulnerable what about the illusion
that you're in control at all yeah let's
start there yeah whole like impulse to
control is actually just a fabrication
yeah I mean you can control what you put
in your mouth but you're not really in
control of anything you like decoupling
that relationship is like the big puzzle
piece yeah I think and really just like
embracing the fact that like you're not
in control and that the path to healing
is about letting go and surrender yeah
which for a type-a personality who's
holding on to everything and it's trying
to will their way in the world that's
like telling somebody that you have to
you know just wave the flag of defeat so
it's a very difficult pill to swallow
and to really just even grok yeah and
and it's also it's so humbling too
because for the first few days there I'm
like wait I can't go to the bathroom
self you know like I somebody has to go
to the bathroom and flush the toilet
yeah you're in a mental institution
right and that you you you I and there
is so much like okay like I I just fully
surrender and it is something that is so
humbling in so many ways and I think
that that's the and I'm I almost I
almost like you get that fight-or-flight
response and after that first week I was
almost like Patton I'm packing it I
don't need this packing up going back
down to San Jose but I'm so glad I stuck
through it and then by the end of my
time there I was almost like no wait but
no I don't want to go I just want to
tell stay yeah this is when it gets
scary to go back into the world yeah it
doesn't I think that that would make my
own decisions there was part of my
thinking it was actually part of the
things that kept me out of treatment I
think for a while and like seeking
treatment because I was afraid that or I
had seen stories of people who almost
like there's just like a revolving door
of treatment facilities because like
then you don't know anything else
because the big bad world is scary out
there well it would be great if we could
all sit around and talk about my
feelings for 10 hours a day but that's
not how life is so it's almost like you
know not staying there too long at the
same time so what is the protocol now
like how do you make sure because you've
been in you know treatment centers
before yeah and have seen what has
happened when you haven't had like
active you know aftercare and you know
really made your recovery a life
priority yeah you know it that I mean I
think that's the greatest unknown and
that's so you set up I set up as much
guardrails and support as I could coming
back here I started work initially
part-time and then I was still doing
more like an intensive outpatient so it
was kind of doing the - and then you so
you slowly stepped down and then right
now I have kind of an outpatient team
mhm
and then really just setting up a
support network and for me that I have a
great support network but it's making
sure that I actually
use it and actually reaching out of
being saying like hey I need help and
this thing that we talked a lot about
that treatment is outing yourself I'm
just saying like hey guys I have to out
myself right now I'm having really bad
disordered thoughts and I just need to
tell somebody and put it out there cuz
when I put it out there then it doesn't
hold as much power over me yeah and you
have to do that in real time when it's
occurring because the tricky thing is
when that moment arises when you're you
know staring at a plate of food and
you're thinking about like not eating it
it's too late like then they're like
call somebody but that that train left
the station a long time ago maybe months
ago like it's it's about the daily habit
of checking in with people and people
who know you and can monitor like hey
you're a little off today what's going
on and kind of compelling you to be
honest yeah exactly it's having that
support system and network and and
really for me fully owning that there
are some things that I can't be
completely self reliant on right now you
know and and that's a bitter pill to
swallow for somebody who likes to be
fully self-reliant but there have been
times and coming back to the bay area
and coming back to work where I realized
like I need to set up like I need to set
up dinners with folks right now to like
go out and eat with them because it's
better I do much better in like a social
scenario than that then when I'm by
myself
right well now you're publicly on the
hook I know the entire world right so
it's I mean it's a double-edged sword
because I did have some people reach out
to me and say oh well now everybody's
watching me you can't screw up uh-huh
and all of a sudden my heart was like
like I'm human I'm gonna screw up I've
screwed up like we're all gonna ask her
us and I think it's you know with with
alcohol or drugs it's very easy to name
your screw ups because it's like I did
the sub sensor I didn't do the sub sense
food it's very very super he's not
binary no it's very it's like did I
restrict that meal a little or did I am
I really eating
you know so gotta really be in touch
with yourself and and you know be
willing to have that kind of honest
dialogue going on all the time like it's
about your intentions as much as
anything else right but you know the the
the authenticity and the vulnerability
with which you you know kind of have
offered this up to the world I think is
honorable and and and super courageous
and I don't say that in a perfunctory or
light way like it was I know it was a
move that like you you know had a lot of
consternation about like should I show
you know should I talk publicly about
this you don't have to you have no
obligation to you made that decision I
was on the I went to the website for
Opel because yes this is about and they
they had like a there's like a slogan on
the home page that is beauty in
imperfection and authenticity and that's
lovely
right because we're all imperfect and I
think the the path towards being that
fully integrated person who's not living
with that kind of dissonance requires
you know the courage to be authentic in
real time you know and to be human and
to be you know exposed on some level and
you know I can't imagine what it felt
like after you wrote that blog post and
you like hit you know publish on it like
walk me through that it was actually the
most freeing experience and I've ever
had I sat down and I bawled my eyes out
for the next half an hour or so as you
were writing it or after you after I
said I mean I sources the catharsis cuz
I had been writing it you know over like
a span of since I mean I left treatment
at the end of June and then so it took
me like a few weeks to kind of wrap my
brain around it and I was so anxious I
remember that day before I was going to
publish it was all done it was sitting
it was ready to go and I remember
actually going to the pool to swim that
morning and then just like it was like
the best one of my life because it was
just like anxiety or something like that
fueled but in in putting it out there it
finally I just I cried because it was
just I finally felt true to myself
mm-hmm and what was the motivation
behind doing that honestly a lot of it I
hate to say that there was a selfish
motivation because it was it was almost
a an alignment for myself yeah you know
people are like oh would you were you
you're so great you're inspiring other
people and I'm like that's okay
discomfort of living in that kind of
dissonance becomes intolerable exactly
and and I don't I can't say why exactly
I felt the need to a load it to the
entire world as opposed to just because
I understand there are portions of
yourself that you can keep close you
know and you don't have to let everybody
know your dirty laundry but for me it
was very important to have that be a
part of my story considering I've been
so open and vulnerable about many other
things but not this and then that kind
of selectiveness didn't sit well with me
right and just to be able to be feel
free I felt very very free after I
apologetic day and I was like I was the
most just free feeling and then people
start giving me negative feedback and
then that went away well 24 hours was
great I don't know I'm sure you know
well look first of all shame can't
survive the light right so whatever
shame you were harboring the only way
out of that is to do exactly what you
did and I'm sure there's trolls out
there whatever but like all I saw was
this overwhelming like outpouring of
like love and support like it was like
it would be it was like a viral moment
in the in the endurance sports world I
did I honestly will say I expected a
reaction
I did not expect that type of attention
to it and I'm blown away in the best way
possible I mean I I was it was amazing
like I mean I get kind of like choked up
thinking about it
because people were so supportive and so
great I'm still like sorting through
emails to respond to people and I think
for me it was very important to talk
about it to you at a time where I had
not recovered and and that was that was
that's a bit tough because I think that
you see so many people talk about their
disorders in the past or their
addictions in the past but it comes from
a recovered perspective and I you know I
got a lot of feedback saying like thank
you for being open before you're there
you know because it's not as simple as
that and and I go back and forth on
whether like total freedom is possible
I feel like the voices get quieter thing
things like they get easier the further
and further like you get into recovery
but I think that you always kind of have
to be vigilant and I maybe you can speak
to that - yeah I mean I'm of the mind
that that there is no recovered there's
recovery there's being active in your
recovery I would never consider myself
recovered ya know and and you know I had
a relapse eight years ago after I've
been sober for thirteen years like I'm
very aware of how fragile it is and how
how it requires you know constant
attention and focus and you know that's
not to say that you know your situation
is the same you know it's different but
I would be curious about it like is
there a sense like that there is a
recovered when it comes to relationship
with food I just feel like that impulse
is always there and and keeping it at
bay you know is important and there's
tools for doing that but to fall under
the belief that it could disappear
altogether and never reappear I think is
dangerous yeah I think there's different
mindsets
um I think some people think that if you
don't give if you don't believe and that
fully recovered is possible then you
know you're never going to get there but
I maybe this might be more of the
unpopular opinion but I do kind of
similarly believe to what you do is that
you know like you can be in a very very
good place of recovery but you still
need to be mindful of things and
especially the longer you know like this
has been 20 years of my life and a lot
of this stuff has become so ingrained
and automatic in me and so it's almost
in some ways like exposure therapy and
unlearning habits and things like that
that didn't happen overnight you know
yeah and it's all about where you are in
the moment like my relationship with
this is like what am i doing today like
where where is my recovery like in the
middle of this experience that we're
having right now because I know people
with 30 days of sobriety who like are
super sober and I know people who've
been sober for 35 years who are out of
their minds right they may not drink but
they're not they don't have they don't
have like emotional sobriety which is
really kind of like where there's no
there's no there's no destination for
that because you can always hit a rate
and improve on you know who you are as a
human being so it's less about where are
my cravings for alcohol right now then
than it is about like what's up with my
character defects like being married to
my wife like I don't want her to leave
like so I I have to like be on top of
this [ __ ]
it's funny when as soon as as soon as I
started to realize that like the food
was no longer like the the scary issue
and I was god now I have to work on
myself right it's like now I have to
like kind of like underbelly things that
is the point versus driving you like
this is this is all about that right and
I and I think my big thing is that I I'm
a thinker and I've always like no no no
I know my feelings for so many years I
was really good at thinking about my
feelings like really really good like
thinking about my feelings but not
actually feeling anything
and I think that actually in our society
we prize a lot of thinking over feeling
you know a lot of people who fall like
the stoic like philosophies and things
like that and and once I finally started
to like tap into what am I feeling right
now and like then just like not even not
even a signing and like not assigning
judgments to that but and then just
actually like being like feelings are
valid too it doesn't all have to come
from the mind yeah you know yeah I think
if you're you know things like stoicism
art great for like corralling your
emotional statement but I think when it
comes at the cost of of valuing your you
know emotional landscape then you're
missing a bigger picture of what it
means to be full of fully integrated
human mm-hmm you know and the thing
about feelings is they change right so
when you feel like you're gonna die or
this is so painful that you can't go one
more minute without picking up the drug
or vomiting or whatever it is your thing
is to be able to just be be with it and
feel it and experience it knowing that
it will go away like it will dissipate
it will morph into something else yeah
and that you don't need to use your
coping mechanism of choice to to get rid
of that to manage that fear because
you're so terrified of feeling that
feeling that you'll do anything to numb
it out to change your state right and
then longer that we go without feeling
those feelings then the more scared we'd
come up them right so it's not entirely
exactly that entire avoidance and so
that's why I've been a huge fan of just
like exposure therapy in a lot yeah well
one of the things you do everyday and
you share it a lot is effect gratitude
last yeah I do that has been and that
actually is started my friend Matt Davis
who's actually a fellow podcaster but he
in recovery himself and kind of started
this movement and it's just on Instagram
and it's 10 things a day that you're
grateful for which actually seems like a
lot and it can be a lot but
it's been very kind of like a it's
different it's a tool in my toolkit no
on a daily basis yeah yeah I mean that's
a big 12-step thing yeah yeah absolutely
because it's one thing to kind of
intellectually grapple with gratitude
but feeling it is like a practice like I
don't I'm not like inclined to walk
around grateful I have to you know what
I mean like I'm like thinking about what
I don't have you know all the time so
and that's not healthy you're good yeah
like I have to go out of my way to go
what am i grateful for and not just go
oh I'm grateful for this this and this
like let me try to feel that yeah like
its foreign it is foreign I think there
there is a part of me though that with
the gratitude a lot of people are moving
towards I mean the power of gratitude
it's great but I also think that there
are there's an issue that if we then
feel like for ungrateful or if we have
negative feelings and that's not right
because we've so much that we should be
grateful for and then we beat ourselves
up that we are you know exactly exactly
but it is a very good like daily
practice yeah we should be grateful for
all our human flaws right I suppose so
alright so you were in the treatment
center for like 90 days yeah so I was it
was about three months ago yeah I think
that's the appropriate time yeah I mean
I everybody should at least three months
everyone's journey is different I think
that they say in terms of like neural
reprogramming and things like that I
think three months this is probably like
is a good period of where you can start
to actually like you know change those
neural pathways I was in for a hundred
days
yeah just like down the street from
where you grew up oh really
you know Newburgh yeah yeah yeah about
that later so here you are you've
emerged from this experience you've
shared it and transparent you've been
open and now you're kind of being
perceived in this new light like now the
it went from like oh you're so inspiring
for what you do athletically
like oh it's so inspiring that you you
know allowed yourself to be vulnerable
like the strength and vulnerability
that's really connecting with a lot of
people and I think this is really it is
whether this is your intention or not
like it is this amazing opportunity for
you to be of service to a lot of people
I mean we have an epidemic of disordered
eating and eating disorders there are so
many people that struggle with this that
suffer in silence and to be you know
this sort of beacon of hope in in all of
its you know flaws and all of that given
that you're early in this process I
think is you know is is really a
beautiful new you know chapter for you
yeah and I you know I don't I look I I
don't have a crystal ball to let you
know like where I'm gonna be and but it
is you know for me it's really an
opportunity to kind of live all parts of
my life like I like I said I think I
said I was like I don't I don't want to
be like the eating disorder recovery
girl I don't want to be the athlete I
don't like this is just me like I'm
super flawed I'm super complex just like
everybody else out there and this is
just another piece you know so I'm just
trying to live authentically and
stumbling through and figuring this all
out and to me it's been very very
connecting to so many different people
yeah well what I hear on that is a
healthy relinquishment of control like
you can't control whatever the media
narrative is going to be around this and
but you do have the ability to reframe
your own story to make it more expansive
than Amelia the the you know obstacle
course champion or Amelia the ultra
athlete or Amelia the the the attorney
like you're a spiritual being having a
human experience and all of its you know
wondrous beauty and and pain where this
goes we don't know but I would imagine
this has now put you in a in a situation
in which you have to figure out yet
another relationship with sport right
like how are you now kind of venturing
forward in in that world yeah so I spent
a lot of time and a lot of my work
and treatment was kind of was being very
curious about my relationship with sport
and about my identity as an athlete and
where that where that fits in in my life
and so I'm still I still have a pole to
sport it's not going anywhere I think
for me it's very much more for the
experiences now I I have I haven't heard
she compete and I actually I think I
went to one portion of myself or I went
to like one side or I used to be all
about the competition in the winning and
then I moved to this
it doesn't matter Whitney doesn't matter
a competition doesn't matter I'm gonna
enter these races where nobody finishes
right yeah and now I'm kind of
recognizing like my therapist told me
she goes you know wanting to win a race
isn't a bad thing it's just what you do
when you don't win that race and so I
still I spent a lot of time you know
working and evolving that that
relationship with competition and lots
to say on that at some point I'm sure
but so now I'm I'm I'm looking you know
to get back into racing and again and
get back into sport just probably not
you know I kind of just things that kind
of light my soul on fire when I talk to
my coach about it he's always and I
talked to about a race and he goes well
does it light you up and I and that's
kind of my my gauge about where I really
want to go with this and I so I've kind
of taken a step back in the early stages
of recovery from competing just because
I'm glad you have a coach yes yes he has
he has been with me from I mean he
inherited me with the well inherit like
I started working with him and then a
week later I ended up with my stress
femur stress fracture and that was not
his fault at all I'm clearly because it
was already there but has actually been
like the greatest source of me really
you know owning this journey and seeking
treatment and recovery and went on are
you physically like cool now is
everything yeah aside from when I kicked
a bench in the sonim
my toe the other day that was annoying
but physically beyond that yes I am I'm
healthy and it's as I told everybody
running feels great when you feed
yourself properly my calcaneal stress
fracture healed in record time when I
was there treatment you know putting
nourishment in your Bo exactly yeah yeah
well I think I told you this before but
I think that you and Buerkle should do
ohto well cuz is super fun you know and
it's so different and like there would
be no expectations and it's difficult
and it's cold and miserable and awesome
and you know that's a lot unlike
anything you've ever done before
yeah and to do it with a teammate also
makes it not really about you and your
performance right and I think you I
think you know with all swimming you've
been doing that could be fun
I want you guys to do that I want it
we've we've talked about it I know they
have a race down here which I think
would be kind of a good like testing of
it I'm doing my first ocean swim
tomorrow so with a nice Caroline right
yeah with Caroline and but in that
that's very different ocean swim then
you know the race are yours going down
because I haven't done I've not really
never saw him in the ocean before but
it's like a nice warm summer ocean a
little you know but you know I'm like
I'm not a great swimmer nobody's ever
actually watch me swim but I wouldn't
worry about it yeah well I wanna I want
to kind of round this down by talking a
little bit about you know for people
that are listening who either are
suffering from this or they're a parent
who has a child suffering from live so
they have a family member or something
like that I think it could be really
instructive and helpful to kind of walk
through you know how how you know people
can manage this like what to look out
for you know how to try to help somebody
who is in this condition and like what
not to do yeah
well I think first of all one big thing
to recognize is that it's not about the
weight and I think or when you if you up
in terms of approaching somebody that
you never know how people are gonna take
it if you say hey notice you've lost a
lot of weight or you've like you know
like so it's very it's more about
pointing out to people like behaviors or
them withdrawing or just really just
checking in on them being like I notice
you've been kind of like not showing up
to group runs or group dinners or you
know like what's going on because as I
know my doctor's always told my parents
is like you can't recover for her like
you can't force her to recover until
she's ready but it's kind of just that
like reinforcement that you are there
for them and that you know in checking
in on them and I think that sometimes
though when things are dire like if it
does seem to be like a medical necessity
state sometimes you have to be the bad
guy I mean I might when my roommates
intervened with me in college I didn't
speak to them for the next several
months
like literally was so angry but they you
know helped save my life
and so in situations like that sometimes
if you're willing to be the bad guy it
can be very useful to just go straight
for it the tough love thing the tough
love and I'm sure and you know like
anybody who's ever had an intervention
done for them like you hate everybody in
that moment but it can be completely
necessary yeah it can be and sometimes
it works and often it doesn't because
that person isn't willing so I think for
anybody who's listening who's
considering intervening on somebody
else's situation it's important I mean
there may be a good reason to do that
and it might be advised but I think it's
important to have
a healthy relationship with outcomes and
not be attached to whether it's gonna
work right yeah no absolutely and no
into going into it that you know there's
a risk that could completely implode
your relationship and but eight you know
it's it's yeah I look back at all of
this now and like man you know I'm
trying to figure out like what actually
like stuck you know the times that
people what people said and there's no
rhyme or reason to be totally honest
because I've had interventions or people
say things to me at times where it
didn't it didn't resonate and then other
times where it's just an offhand comment
not mm-hmm yeah timing is a weird thing
with this site right you have to you
have it's like you've got to live your
life in a certain way and get to the
point where you really want to do
something you know and and nobody can
compel that willingness no no and I
think it well unless you clearly have
like a minor child or things like that
or are there are situations but you
can't make somebody want it no I mean
you can make somebody go to a place
right and you can you know get them set
somewhere but you can't actually
catalyze their desire to actually be
healthy no and and they'll go through
the motion and I did it I went through
the motions I did everything that you
know you you said I should do and you
know God discharged and went on my way
and so and then I've had people say okay
well then Amelia what's different about
this time then you know and honestly I I
could say well who knows but I think
that for me it's this time it came from
myself and that's really like the key
difference you know as opposed to
somebody else kind of pushing you
towards it yeah yeah well I think the
thing for you is just like I said before
like is really having a setup that holds
you accountable like a community of
people that you talk to and you know a
protocol that's keeping you on
on the path yeah yeah I think that's
it's so so important and and with you
know anybody and going through any type
of recovery from any type of mental
illness or mental health issue what are
the signs to look out for like what are
some things that the people that are in
the grips of this thing yeah do like
early before it's obvious before like if
a parents listening to this and like
what should they be looking out for um I
will say I'm aware it's hard to
generalize because they are so different
but I would say Skippy meal times are
like finding excuses this is my own
experience so finding excuses to not eat
with people you know subtly kind of like
restricting food intake being very kind
of secretive around food is something to
look out for body image talk things
along those lines
that well but and that's tough because
there's so much worried we're in crazy
town
I know I know and so it is tough to say
like when somebody like pokes out
themselves and I was like I don't like
how I look I'm like is that is that the
news order is that right are you like
looking at the Kardashians all day long
in your Instagram feed right what are
you doing right yeah I mean as a parent
of two daughters like we're you know
we're in the middle of all this right
now with our 15 year old like she just
deleted everybody
she's only follows her friends now good
for you know and that's a big part of it
I think that's huge I think that and I
know me personally I have unfollowed
anybody who's like seems to be promoting
that type of like diet culture and and
that you know anything that wouldn't be
that wouldn't be conducive to like my
own recovery but I do think that you
know with with teenagers and you know
with kids the probably one of the best
things that you can do as a parent and I
say that's actually not as a parent is
just being a role model in like in how
you how you approach food you know and
because people don't realize that kids
pick up on a lot of stuff you know
so if you sit there and demonize certain
foods or you know a lot of diet talk
like kids can pick up on that and I say
this and you know like that was never
that was never in my family my family
didn't have any of that disorder or diet
Hawk yet I still have an eating disorder
so at some point for parents I think
it's also that you know it's it's not
always on you you know it's it's not
your fault
as well and I think as an athlete like
in in the athletic context it's very
easy to hide your disorder yeah you know
under the mask of like training and
performance and I think that there's you
know there's a lot of people you know
amateur athletes and endurance sports
and other sports that are actively in
the throes of this and you know it's
just not evident it's it's harder to
spot it's harder to spot because you can
frame it in terms of like well I'm but
I'm doing it for performance I'm
imagining right yeah just a female
absolutely and I think it's even it's
even tougher for men because I think
it's not as I don't say socially
acceptable to have any of you sort of
but if there is like you know what
they're not as many men speak out about
it it's a little bit of there's a weird
like kind of like tinge of taboo around
yeah yeah and there are there are some
Mario fairly as like spoken out about
his and whatnot um but I think that you
know and in in the athletic world yeah
it's it's absolutely difficult and
what's unfortunate is that some of the
times that I think that I have actually
been struggling the worse have been the
times where I have looked the most
health like the most quote unquote
normal outwardly and that there are many
people in normal size or larger size
bodies who are really really struggling
but because they don't have the physical
manifestation of it it's harder to pick
up well no one would identify it right
and luckily the you know the even sort
of treatment model and everybody in the
industry is finally started to realize
that you can have any disorder of an any
size body so
that's been very important so I think in
terms of picking up it's picking up you
know signs it's it's mainly about
behaviors because body size is not it's
not gonna indicate anything yeah
the social what you're all to I think
the social withdraw yeah in any time and
I think really you know avoiding
mealtimes keeping that kind of stuff is
is a is a big red flag yeah all right
well let's let's land this plane right
and final question which is is there
anything that like you want to say to
like is there anything that you feel
like is misunderstood about you and this
story that you want to like make clear
like I feel like it's been completely
embraced but I'm not you so I just want
to make sure that you have the
opportunity to like really speak your
truth and not be misunderstood I am
aware that there are folks out there who
believe that like I should not be
engaging in sport and also be in
recovery and I understand I think that
that's can be a completely valid concern
it is also something that I've worked
through a lot like with my with my
treatment team and everyone's
relationship with movement is entirely
different
and so for some people it shouldn't be a
part of the recovery for others people
it can be and I continually it's part of
mine now but you know I continually
every single day constantly question
that and very very always curious and
like and as we've talked as you talked
about and that you know my trading one
compulsion for another but I think the
key is just to be very curious about
your intentions and your motivations
behind things and you know it's I'm
always a work in progress as we all are
he says otherwise don't trust them I
mean I'm just like I don't I don't have
anything figured out I'm just stumbling
around like putting the pieces together
and how your parents doing very good I
think about their I I love my parents
they're so fantastic and they've just
they've been kind of those like silent
supporters that that will be there for
me and I think that they're they're
really they're excited to see me not so
much I mean yes like you know be in
recovery for that you know sort of but
just to be more like living person every
scene life that's what that's the way I
kind of look at this whole thing from
10,000 feet like you're on this journey
to becoming a fully integrated
actualized you know authentic human
being and you had to take these
disparate you know puzzle pieces and
find a way to put them together so like
you're assembling yourself in a new way
and I think the more you create that
alignment and that consistency in all
these various areas and you know writing
this blog post and being here today are
a big part of that it's gonna just it's
gonna lead to something like amazing and
beautiful because the pout there's so
powerful to be in that place of truth
and honesty or you're not shying away or
feeling shame or feeling like you know
you have to like couch your words
because you don't want to say this or
that like now you can just be who you
are and stand in that and what people in
the eye and that's just like a it's it's
like a very powerful place to be so I
think whatever's coming next for you I'm
super excited to see what that is
thank you I am excited as well you know
I think I'm hopeful I'm hopeful cool all
right well I think it was courageous of
you to come here today and share all
that so I acknowledge you for that and I
thank you for that and I think it's
gonna be helpful to a lot of people so I
appreciate it all right and if you want
to connect with Amelia Amelia Boone
Racing calm Millie Boone on all the
social platforms separate Instagram
oh hey are viewing AR Boone 11 what
happened there somebody take your name
no um I was very late to the Instagram
game and I also didn't expect that I
mean sorry I'm should give it to you I
tried a million beer in Silicon Valley
you can't get that sorted out I tried to
get a million com2 and that person
didn't know it's that person Wow he
keeps it for his granddaughter or
something like that
I'm serious I've tried to hunt him down
and pay him for it
alright well come back and talk to me
again peace food
[Music]